this is the feejee bandit iguana a  creature is stunning as it is rare  native to the tiny Fiji Islands in the  South Pacific it is one of the most  geographically isolated iguanas in the  world vibrant like a jewel these  reptiles are considered a national  treasure by the government of Fiji their  emerald green colored skin is sensitive  to light and can change color to match  its background the male's like this one  are banded with blue streaks their long  spiny toes ending claws to help them  climb but none of these adaptations can  protect this species from the many  threats it faces habitat loss from  development poaching for the illegal pet  trade and introduced predators like rats  cats and mongooses all cloud this  creatures future this is the Fiji banded  iguana  you